[Music]
listen to how this textbook describes
slavery
the master often had a barbecue or a
picnic for his slaves then they had
a great frolic even while working in the
cotton fields they sang songs
the beat of the music and the richness
of their voices made work seem light
yikes
that's from history of georgia a
textbook published in 1954
that was taught across junior high
schools in georgia for decades
that sort of language is part of an
intellectual movement called the lost
cause
a distorted version of american civil
war history that's been prevalent in the
south for a long time
it took shape soon after the defeat of
the confederate states in the war when
southern historians like edward pollard
and former confederate general jubal
early started preserving the south's
perspective through their writings
they framed the confederate cause as a
heroic defense of the southern way of
life
against the overwhelming forces in the
north that narrative has
a few basic tenets the glorification of
confederate soldiers who died for a
cause they believed in
the belief that slavery was a benevolent
institution and maybe most importantly
that
slavery was not the root cause of the
war the lost cause is one of the most
notoriously effective efforts to rewrite
history
and it was done by the losing side so
how did it become
so deeply rooted in southern memory
blame the united daughters of the
confederacy
the udc was founded in nashville in 1894
to preserve confederate culture
for generations to come the women who
made up the group descended from
elite antebellum families and they used
their social and political clout to
spread the pro-southern version of the
war
as real history you've probably seen
their efforts to honor the confederacy
but
maybe you didn't know it was the udc
they're the ones who covered the
southern landscape with memorials for
confederate leaders and soldiers
they used their fundraising and lobbying
skills to pressure local governments
into erecting monuments in prominent
public spaces like courthouses and state
capitals
installed here next to the state capital
by the united daughters of the
confederacy the
united daughters of the confederacy
donated this memorial to the city
back in the 30s they put them along
roadsides and in parks
any place that was remotely relevant to
the confederacy was memorialized
by the early 20th century the udc had a
hundred thousand members and chapters
spread
all over the country but mostly in
former confederate states
and there's a reason they grew so
quickly during that time so we're
talking about
roughly three decades after the end of
the war and the confederate veterans
themselves are beginning to die off so
there is this push
to find ways to commemorate it because
the big
challenge by 1900 was there's a new
generation of white southerners
being born and they never experienced
the war years
that push is visible most of the
confederate monuments were erected
during the udc's height of influence
there's a rhetoric around monuments that
we want to get this thing
built before all of that generation has
died off and the reason
we want it is to teach future
generations about those men
dr karen cox wrote the book on the udc
and i asked her if it was fair to say
the group established the lost cause as
historical fact in the south
oh my god yeah they were the leaders of
the lost calls into the 20th century
and they made it a movement about
vindication just to give you an idea of
how effective they were
they successfully lobbied for a
confederate memorial in arlington
national cemetery which
u.s president woodrow wilson proudly
unveiled to a cheering crowd
now that's influence right monuments are
the least of what they did
uh what i mean they are the most visible
and tangible
but the work with children was far more
influential
it turns out a central udc objective is
shaping how children think about the war
and their southern heritage one of their
most powerful tools
textbooks take a look at this pamphlet
called a measuring rod for textbooks
it was written by the illustrious
southern historian miss mildred
rutherford
an educator orator and author of
southern history textbooks she's also
very pro-slavery the pamphlet announced
the formation of a textbook review
committee featuring prominent
southerners like
five former confederate generals this
group was committed to spreading the
truths of confederate history so they
instructed school boards to reject any
textbooks that did not accord full
justice to the south and they urged
libraries to deface
every book in their collection that
didn't measure up by writing the words
unjust to the south clearly on its cover
this pamphlet was shared widely with
school boards throughout the south
and udc-backed committees closely
monitored history books to make sure
northern influence
never reached classrooms so the core
language of an approved textbook
aligned precisely with that of the lost
cause you know
stuff like the confederacy lost in the
war between the states
but georgia never forgot to honor her
confederate soldiers
history of georgia was on the udc's
approved list it was also written by
e merton coulter a self-described
southern historian
and historian described white
supremacist they understand
that how you educate who wins the
writing game
who wins the battle over history
ultimately wins the war that's the big
fight for the udc but their work with
children went further than the
classrooms
the udc formed an auxiliary group called
the children of the confederacy which
was designed to get kids born in former
confederate states to actively
participate
in their version of history group
leaders had kids recite call and
response truths from something called
the confederate catechism
children up to the age of 18 would
compete and be rewarded for memorizing
long passages of lost cause rhetoric so
it would be
like an after-school thing you know like
that was your club you would go after
school to the meeting
of the children of the confederacy and
your leader might teach you
songs of the south like dixie or other
songs that were considered southern
patriotic songs
they would have them write essays go
visit the veterans
and learn this catechism children were
also the centerpiece of their
community's monument unveilings
like this living flag at the dedication
of the stonewall jackson monument in
richmond yes those are schoolchildren
the udc's efforts
shaped the identities of children who
grew up with the lost cause they made
history personal
and that made their story last longer
generations of generations of children
learning that narrative in a variety of
ways
grow up to be you know segregationists
in the 50s and 60s
because that's been drilled into them
since they were children after world war
one the udc started losing steam
but the damage was done the monuments
were in place and the textbooks they
wrote remained in southern classrooms
until the late
70s and the women's group did it all
without the right to vote
or participate in politics you can still
get glimmers of this lost cause
memory of the war from people who will
always choose to see it through the
personal and i think the udc to a great
extent was
that was their goal so the next time
someone says the confederate monuments
are about remembering our history just
know that that's exactly what the united
daughters of the confederacy
wants you to think
dixie